i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna go totally
cliche stereotypical
this is communism check out the story
from cnbc
all eyes are on this inflation number
which could have the biggest
gain in nearly a decade they say the
consumer price index for april
will be reported on wednesday at 8 30
a.m and is expected to be the hottest
in nearly 10 years economists have said
the jump in inflation looks larger
because the base effects of last year
when prices were weak to the pandemic
shutdowns the specter of inflation has
been spooking investors
so any surprise the upside could uh
surprise
the upside could stress the market this
inflation thing
what is joe biden doing they're mass
printing money mass
spending bill they're policies these are
biden policies that have caused people
to not want to work anymore
it's democrats and republicans together
who have mass printed money i was in
favor i said look when
the 15 days below the spread good faith
effort everyone kind of agreed we got
this crisis and it turned it into a year
and a half you know a year and three
months
and so the economy was just on in flames
and they kept printing money like crazy
what's happening now is if let's say
let's say uh ian
slept on a couch for a week and did no
work and then i worked 40 hours that
week and made 500
ian has no money i have 500 the
government comes in
and starts mass printing money giving
this you know very heavy uh
unemployment ian as somebody who's lying
around hasn't produced any value for the
system
i as someone who worked 40 hours a week
has but now ian has buying power out of
nowhere
which dilutes my buying power so they're
effectively
it's effectively communism and i'm not
saying like literally it's communism but
you have this very authoritarian
government
you have them pushing absurd policies
that are like shutting down pipelines
causing economic
damage and then the mass printing of
money and then this unemployment scheme
and it's just basically stripping away
the buying power from working americans
and giving it to people who aren't
producing and aren't working
that's that's that's what we were warned
about we've got like a ratio because if
i had zero and you had 500
and then they gave everybody 500 so even
this is a good argument for ubi not
being functional
you'd have a thousand i have a 500 i now
have 50 of your purchasing power
before i had zero percent right that's a
huge
increase so that means think about it
this way if i made
40 widgets and you made zero and then i
get 500
and you get uh and you get 500 so i have
a thousand total
they just gave you the ability to take
20 of my widgets away even though i made
them and you made nothing
that's what's happening right now with
all of this spending you you add all of
this
you look at what's going on and it seems
like you're not to be too conspiratorial
anything like that
but maybe these conservatives who are
like you know hannity or rush bang on
the table saying they hate america
they're communists they work completely
wrong
just do you think the authoritarians and
the communists are going to come out and
be like we want to
redistribute wealth from working-class
people to poor people
so we can court you know normalize we
want to take away your ability to drive
we don't want you to have the
independence to to spend your own money
we want to tax the poor they're not
going to come out and say that i mean
bloomberg
did come out and say tax the poor yeah
but they're not going to come and say
that they don't know what's good for
them they're gonna come out and go oh oh
oh gee we
we gotta give everybody unemployment uh
it's it's so it's so sad that the
economy was shut down
and then it's only the blue states that
are still shutting down here's what gets
really crazy
this is what i think is going to be
freaking people out
you see all these signs from these fast
food restaurants where they're like we
quit we won't work here anymore
you saw those we talked about the other
day there's a dollar general where it
says we refuse to work for these wages
in these red states a bunch of the
republican governors announced they will
not be taking any money from biden
this 300 unemployment they ain't going
to take it because people don't want to
work
because you get 16 an hour unemployment
so imagine you live in
mississippi where i think it's one of
the states where they're doing this and
your unemployment's getting caught off
you're like okay
i better go get a job so you go down to
local uh mcdonald's or whatever and you
apply for a job and they're like 13
bucks an hour and you're like
better than nothing then some dude shows
up and he's got like a pink
sweater tied over his shoulders and like
a green pastel shirt he's got aviators
on and his hair slicked back
and he walks and he goes i'll take the
number ten you know give me two number
tens and leave me like two apple pies
and two mcflurries
you know what screw it he dishes out a
bunch of cash and this guy who's working
in mississippi
who's not getting the the unemployment
sees this guy
who comes from a blue state that is the
guy in the blue state did no work he's
in
in the analogy i gave the guy who did
nothing and now has has been given the
buying power of the guy who's doing work
the people in red states are going to be
like nah you come in here with that
money
that was printed that strips our buying
power away
and then buy from us while we work that
means these red states where people are
working
are going to be in effect producing free
of charge
for the blue states especially when it
comes to goods that are transported
across state lines so imagine you work
in mississippi
and you're making uh i don't know what
they made what are they going to be
some what kind of fruit how about uh
georgia they do peaches right peaches
yeah peaches in georgia so i don't know
if george is one of these states but
let's say they're like okay no
unemployment for you
you got to get a job somebody goes i'm
going to go grow peaches then the
peaches get shipped up to new york where
the people
are not working and they're getting free
money from the federal government
while you work on a farm to make those
peaches for 13 bucks an hour they're
getting 16 bucks an hour doing nothing
and getting the fruits of your labor
literally so
you mentioned sorry let me jump in here
because i love the 10th amendment
and this is something that you mentioned
uh before and i don't think any of our
guests have ever really mentioned the
10th amendment the 10th amendment is so
important for allowing the states to do
what the federal government is not
specifically supposed to do
so i wonder this looks like a good
application of the 10th amendment
but to me it also looks like it could be
starting the roots of a civil war
that's a great point and and and yes
i agree with you um i think the way out
of our current
problems of an all-powerful dc is
federalism meaning
those powers that are not specifically
in the constitution enumerated for the
federal government belong to the states
but that is kind of how you begin a bit
of a
of of secession movements and there's a
lot of that in america but there has to
be
some pushback and i don't think it
should come from the people i think it
should become coming from
the governors so like you said the
governors are not going to take cash
governors should uh you know you
mentioned your example which i thought
was was really good and really
illustrative of what's going on
i think there's another factor if i
could add it on is you want to get a job
you go to the mcdonald's
but the vast majority of americans work
in small businesses
and with 150 000 illegals crossing the
border every day i don't need to pay 13
an hour i can charge this guy six and
that's what's gonna happen so now i
can't even get a job for 13
an hour because the market is flooded by
cheap labor so imagine
the crisis you just said but the labor
is the other and our labor is not
constant our labor
pool is growing tremendously with no
consequence so
why are you going to work for 13 an hour
when why am i going to hire you for 13
when joe biden says
it's totally cool to hire that guy for
half well we saw that when
it's dignity under donald trump there
was a raid on a bunch of chicken
processing plants
and i think what is it like six to eight
hundred uh illegal immigrants were
arrested and deported and then local
news went down
they had hiring fairs and they saw a
bunch of people you know a diverse group
of people
showing up and they were like why are
these people coming for a job and they
asked one guy and they were like
why would you want to work for these low
wages and he goes pays 14 bucks an hour
it's more than i was getting at the gas
station so
these companies exploit porous borders
absolutely and it's always been that way
that's why bernie sanders
in 2015 said it is a koch brothers
proposal
to have open borders now the left is all
for it
because they support industrialists i
guess yeah that's the that's the
democratic party
no the republicans are trash oh
absolutely there's like a handful of
good ones i guess
yeah but they're not doing anything
either i feel like uh
i remember when dylan radigan did that
epic rant i don't know if you remember
it back in like 2013 where he said
the democrats the republicans are
burning the system down while democrats
are kicking the can down the road for
future generations
and i'm like kind of feels like it's
inverted at this point republicans are
just sitting there twiddling their
thumbs
watch you know just kicking the can down
the road ignoring the problems while the
democrats are actively burning the
system down
and i think it's because they want to
extra they feel the system is crumbling
so they want to extract as much as they
can for themselves individually
before it all comes tumbling there was a
stick i saw from the 2020
tax returns that blew my mind and it was
i believe it was 62 percent of those who
filed having made more than 500
000 62 were registered as democrats
oh yeah yeah i mean so in in the course
of my lifetime
you're right it has flip-flopped they
are the party of
the rich they are the party of the big
banks they are the party of open borders
and the republicans and now they're the
party of censorship where it was when i
was a kid right it was that
shouldn't be on tv and where our morals
and the answer was if you don't like a
churn the channel
now the right is the one saying well if
you don't like it turn the channel on
the left is saying that shouldn't be
allowed on tv you can't
well i i think it was true it's amazing
i think the the culture war was was
looming and i think
donald trump and bernie sanders were
insurgents trying to break into their
parties
bernie's much too weak and so the
democrats grabbed him by the throat and
said
you know shut up or else and he said
okay i'm so sorry and donald trump was
like no
no and he like kicking tables over and
he's like flipping tables and
you know slamming glasses on the ground
trump's kind of guy
so i've said it before i think when he
got elected the establishment was like
okay donald you won here's the plan he
went
no i don't think so and they're like
you're gonna play ball he's like no i'm
not they're like okay he's a russian spy
yeah there you go oh i agree with you
and bernie as you mentioned uh
earlier you were talking about how going
back quickly to the climate change issue
how
there is such hypocrisy of the people
who push these causes and the opulent
life they live
for me he's a wonderful example i mean
does he have an opulent life maybe not
but he does have three houses four if
you include his
you know i don't have four houses now if
you really believed in the human
ability of anthropo anthropomorphic uh
uh climate change or global warming aegw
and you believe your actions are causing
this well your action of maintaining and
traveling
to four different homes has a carbon
footprint
is bernie gonna give it up no neither is
anyone on that side
so it for me when people like bernie's a
communist i'm like he's not really a
communist no he is he is
he no he's he's a communist party
official right because at the height of
the soviet union the party leaders never
wanted for caviar or vodka
the people were dying in the streets but
they had a very good life and they
supported and toasted the system
bernie is a party leader i really think
that one of the greatest moments in the
history of
government economics or just humanity in
general was when maduro was giving a
speech to his starving people in
venezuela
and he pulls an empanada out of a drawer
and he takes a big bite
because not only was it like insult to
injury that
people are starving and you're eating in
front of him but why did he have an
empanada in his desk drawer in his
office
like hold on maybe i understand you
having some cookies or crackers like
in it somewhere else but it's his work
desk where he's giving his speech from
and he likes look at the camera he leans
in and he pulls an empanada out of a
drawer
that's weird that's like someone having
like an unwrapped snickers in their
pocket
yeah like what is like walking around
spaghetti in your pocket it's like a
weird thing to do
but you gotta love the corruption of the
of these far leftists and with venezuela
you mentioned maduro the richest person
in venezuela is hugo chavez's
ex-wife dead widow right is the richest
person in venezuela so when you were
saying earlier about
those who have purchasing power but have
done nothing to earn it
that is taken to the extreme what has
she done to be working as a man
tens of billions of dollars she hasn't
done produced uh
is it fair that is a quote unquote fair
that that jeff bezos is worth 200
million dollars and am i jealous he just
bought a 500 million dollar
sailing by the way is it funny though
that we are actually arguing from the
left on this point
that these communists and socialists
have done nothing to produce
the wealth and the access that they hold
and we are angry the workers have had
their values stripped away by a crop
system exactly
maybe that's that you're right
that is a brilliant that's a great point
yeah now we sound like
old-school lefties we sound we we we
sound like like old union uh uh
what's his name of jimmy hoffa this this
is the problem i have with us with with
the unions with the left is that
they've clearly been corrupted by the
the by the industrialists by the
industry by the by the by the corrupt by
the crony capitalists by the
establishment politicians
who just want to extract value from the
working class and the problem is
the younger leftists aren't experienced
enough to understand they're being
exploited and they just play right into
it
so it's funny when you see all of these
people who voted for joe biden
they're young people who don't
understand who they're voting for and
i'm like you're voting for joe biden
yeah well trump's a fascist i was like
do you have any idea who you're talking
about with joe biden
he he was overseeing iraq for the bite
for the obama administration
and his brother gets his contracts to
build you know you know in iraq becoming
a millionaire
the obama administration killed a bunch
of people started a bunch of wars
i don't care if you don't like trump but
stop pretending like biden is in any way
good yeah and and
no that's that that's a great point my
idea just went right out of my head i
was
talking we talked about oh and and and
purchasing power so you said the way we
were talking about
you know we now sound like leftists
talking about exploiting the workers
as opposed to you know the
industrialists or the the people that
own all the the wealth
the left has become the right ah i lost
my train of thought sorry
i'll get back to you the left has become
the right point that's why i've had like
a couple jokes where i've been like
you know it's about time the workers
stood up to the exploitation of the
establishment politics
and maybe maybe the the the workers of
the world should unite and push me back
oh and yes and that's that was sorry did
am i cutting you off no go ahead
well that's that was my point of of the
value of you use the phrase a couple
times of like paying into the system or
buying into the system or contributing
to the system
and that was a little bit of of what i
found fascinating with the early
occupy wall street movement and i
remember one of the leaders of it and
i'm not making fun of the guy
but he was talking about his huge
student loan debt because he had gotten
advanced degrees in puppetry
and and he couldn't pay off his student
loans and that's the problem i have with
elizabeth warren's proposal of paying
off student loans is
you value very highly your degree in
medieval literature
you value to the point of three hundred
thousand dollars in debt at yale
i don't know that doesn't mean society
or the markets or
and that doesn't mean therefore that i
should have to pay off your debt
i i i i was down there like if i well
yeah that's why i mentioned that's why i
didn't know this
i knew it all went together and i was so
mad i lost my train of thought earlier
under employed puppeteer joins by wall
street
and they say a few years ago he
graduated from the nyc
teaching fellows program where he's a
full-time drama teacher a public teacher
he's a country school 35 000 in student
loans
and now he's like give me money i saw a
meme
where someone was like it you know these
these bourgeois leftists are like oh you
should pay off our student loan debt
because
just because you were able to pay your
debt doesn't mean we should suffer
and i was just like i think asking the
working class to pay
the debts of the wealthiest uh the
highest salary earners in the country is
like
pretty far right and people are like oh
like what do you call it i guess not far
right not the right answer but what do
you call it
when the ultra wealthy i shouldn't say
ultra off because it's like the 0.1
percent
what do you call it when the when the
rich people the the highest salary
owners in the country
demand of the working class and the poor
to pay
their debts for them yeah slavery i
guess communists do that right
it's like roman old roman slavery yeah
yeah yeah your citizens and then
everyone else
the the period or whatever the greeks i
mean it was just you had like citizens
and then you had
everyone else in society and they would
basically work for the citizens
yeah and the greek philosopher king
system gave us
really the foundation of western thought
right but they did have a whole boatload
of slaves to make that system keep that
system afloat
and so i don't i'm i've always had a
little thing against academia there's a
great quote by fulton sheen a
famous catholic priest up for sainthood
and he has this funny quote he says that
intelligentsia
is uh when you educate someone beyond
his intelligence
and i think that's a great quote right
so i've always had a problem a little
bit with the intelligentsia
again go get your phd in in medieval
poetry that's fascinating
but it doesn't really contribute to
society and anything other than the
intellectual way
and if someone is not sustaining your
livelihood as a medieval poetry
professor
then it is it is communism it is a form
of slavery really or totalitarianism to
then come to the working class and say
and therefore now you must and that's
what they do
and that is what is happening so it's
really funny that
in this sense the trump supporters were
far left they wanted the union jobs back
they wanted the jobs brought back to the
country they wanted manufacturing jobs
they wanted to work
they were tired of being exploited by
the ultra elites the people who are
rigging the system
and the leftists are the college
graduates who want the poor people to
pay their bills
and want the establishment to go bomb
other countries not all the leftists a
lot of
this don't like any of that stuff but
they're willing to support it yeah so
i think one of the greatest things that
i'm sorry that's a um
what what's a collaborator is the right
word um conspirator conspirators
co-conspirators that's what they would
say so these leftists these dsa types
who voted for biden are conspirators in
their own terminology
and based on the ideology of the trump
supporters they're actually further left
than they are
in the sense that they support the
workers rights they're not communists
though
but even so as as center right
defending workers they're still somehow
further left than
the leftists who are like bourgeois
right authoritarians yeah and their
salon
right like like sipping expensive
liqueurs and and talking
lofty thoughts i remember the first job
i got in a campaign um
the campaign manager said we don't need
anyone here who wants to sit in a room
and think lofty thoughts
like the first job was we have to blow
up balloons right and
and it's not fun to blow up 5 000
balloons but someone has to do it but
you meet a lot of these campaign people
who are like
well i really love to think about like
trade policy okay kid you know what
we need you to set up chairs and blow up
balloons
and we have a lot of that we have a lot
of the the people who want to think
lofty thoughts and they want other
people
to finance it and and there's going to
be some violent pushback if
that movement grows thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time